hello everyone this next game was played
in the 1966 the Chess Olympiad in Havana
Cuba and the Soviets sent a really
strong team to play first board was
played by Tegan Petrosyan the reigning
world champion aboard number two was
Boris Spassky Michael towel was board
number three and board number four was
Leon each time and Damon had to reserve
reserves were Viktor Korchnoi in las
Pulgas key and it's a good thing they
sent reserves because mikhail tal was
forced to miss for the first four rounds
as he was in a hospital before before
round one even started michael towel was
flirting with someone's wife and he got
hit on the head with a bottle and got
beaten up so he was unable to play the
first four round and this is round
number five so Michael tall is freshly
out of the hospital and ready to play
some good chess so tell his wife and his
opponent is a grandmaster from worldwide
Alfredo Oliviera and subways efore a
solid opening after four days in a
hospital we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 Bishop to b5 the real opus a6
Bishop day for Knight to f6 South
castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1 b5
Bishop to b3 this is all standard theory
at the time d6 c3 Bishop to g4 h3 Bishop
to h5 and now South plays d4 and here
but what gets a bit greedy he plays a
Bishop captures an f3 he's going for
this d4 pawn but stall doesn't mind
about his d4 pawn and he plays Queen
captures on f3 we have a captures on d4
and now now plays Queen to g3
now attacking this g7 pawn and in this
position probably probably the best move
is the castle but Olivia are played King
to f8 if he decided to cancel here to
the the game would probably continue it
with something like Bishop to h6
night to h5 attacking the Queen and
defend
on g7 and then simply Queen to g4 and
probably Olivia didn't wanna go into
these kinds of complications as well the
Black Knight is now attacked he can go
back to s6 as it will be checkmate on g7
and well black cannot capture the bishop
and h6 as it's been so after putting the
g3 he decided to go for Queen King to f8
topless Queen to d3 and we have D
captures on c3 and Lancaster's on c3 and
okay black is up upon but his King is on
I faith and this will take some time for
for black to develop we have nice 85
attacking the Queen Queen three to c5
Bishop d3 d4 Knight to d5 Knight
captures on d5 and not Bishop captures
on d5 and this bishop is not a monster
it goes to d5 with a tempo on the rook
and since black doesn't have a light
squared bishop there is no peace that
can oppose this bishop
okay just nice will be able to kick it
from d5 but it will take some time for
the Knights to get there
rough day 7 getting out of the way and
also it will come in handy to defend
this f7 square table is rotated e1 and
well here probably a lot of moves are
playable and the Bitola Viera decided to
go to go for the attack key plays g5 as
he plays g5 and is preparing a move like
route to g8 or depending on what style
plays even h5 and going for a full
attack but Sally immediately plays Queen
to h5 and this starts this threat of h5
and also is buying this ff7 point very
nicely after the nice moves this can get
ugly so you can replace Bishop to f6 and
this is a good move it procures it
prepares the bishop to go to g7 it's
needed to defend from some kind of
checks and also makes room for this roof
to defend f7 so tau plays f4 we have DK
person f4 and a bit of cat person
four and now this bishop is ready to
remove one defender from the FDS seven
square olivia replace rock the g8 and
thous rock to f1 and this is a very nice
move
we have rook to g6 bye-bye Oliviera and
this is actually this is actually a
blunder that well it doesn't lose the
game immediately but Olivia decides not
to play this game anymore as he's
planning to go pink to be seven and then
plague Quincy g8 and go for some sort of
an attack here but stop simply plays
Queen captures an 87 and in this
position Olivia resigned the game
because the idea of king going to e7 is
no longer possible if King would go to
Eastern and then simply Bishop captures
the knight and the wall this one's Abby
says f7 pawn cannot be defended and if
black would play something like for
example roof to d7 to defend against any
threats of this well rook opening up the
file then simply again Bishop captures
on e5 and now the bishop cannot capture
because then Queen captures on g6 would
be over so he has to play something like
D captures only five and here it all has
a fancy move to finish the game Bishop
to e6 and it's completely winning the
rook captures the rook and e1 has Queen
captures I have seven is checkmate and
the black doesn't really have a move she
just has to make any move and then white
will simply grab this rook and this game
over
so yeah but none of this none of this
happened after being captured on eight
seven alfredo Olivia resigned and yeah
Tommy thought they'd missed four games
in a row before the first four rounds
but then he won all of the games he
played after that and the Drude two
games yeah he played the entire Olympia
without a loss and well it's no wonder I
mean
topping board three the Soviets really
sent in a team for over killing say but
you know like I said Sal doesn't just to
go play a tournament
you know go home he there always has to
be some kind of a story about Tao and
yeah getting his head smashed with a
bottle and getting hospitalized for four
days that's definitely quite a story and
yes that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and yeah before
I forget I started watching this series
I it's not that new actually it's called
the black mirror so if you do get a
chance I would recommend it to everyone
and I would be interested to know what
you think and that's it thanks for
watching everyone and also before I
forget thank you for that Fred Ackerman
for your contribution to my channel I
really appreciate it and see you soon
guys